the disastrous flooding in and around
Houston is a huge challenge for the
region's medical centers about 20
hospitals have evacuated or could
discontinued service in the Greater
Houston area since Harvey made landfall
as many as 1500 patients have been
transferred
while most hospitals remain open some
have only limited access to medicine
food and power Kris Van Cleave is
outside ben taub hospital near the
center of Houston with a look at how the
historic flooding is affecting patient
care Chris good morning good morning
during the height of the storm over the
weekend water around this hospital
reached almost waist-deep now that
essentially cut off the 350 or so
patients inside from being able to read
be resupplied with food or medicine
three critical patients had to be
evacuated and while they have food at
least through today and conditions
around here have improved hospitals
across this region are struggling to
treat patients during this unfolding
disaster we were a little nervous who
would make it in time so it's nice to
have a good thing come out of something
so scary
so scary because as Harvey dumped record
rain flooding Houston Sarah hunter went
into labor he has a flair for the
dramatic that's for sure but she and her
husband Wesley had decided to ride out
the storm at a hotel close to the
hospital just in case and sure enough
little Elliott came a week early
we wouldn't been able to make it to the
hospital if I had in the hospital picked
this hotel as part of their hurricane
preparedness plan for a reason they
wanted women who are in high-risk
pregnancies people who could go into
labor during the storm to be at the
Marriott because it's just steps away
from Children's Hospital right there and
across the street there is another
emergency room is your house okay dr.
Brent Cassini leads the emergency
management team at Texas Children's
Hospital where Elliot and 26 others have
been born since Saturday Harvey has been
that it's been a kind of an ongoing
issue so it's been days on days but the
staff was ready for that and the
hospital was designed to resist a post
hurricane flood you have flood doors in
the basement levels that are essentially
like submarine doors that shut us off
from the rest of the Texas Medical
Center underground Children's has only
seen minor leaks
you can see a tree down there but north
of downtown rising floodwaters forced
st. Luke's vintage hospital to evacuate
29 patients Monday using boats and
trucks our biggest concern was the water
that surrounded the hospital
accessibility and we did have some water
that got into our main power house where
all of our operational power and needed
life-sustaining equipment comes from
about 40 nurses and staff are still
stranded inside the hospital their
houses have been destroyed and they are
not able to return home but like so many
emergency workers they stayed on the job
helping patients like Sarah her husband
and newborn baby every single staff
member and nurse and doctor that's been
here they have family members for them
to stay focused on my family that really
really means a lot to me
hospitals made a host of improvements
after Alison hit in 2001 in paralyzed
this region certainly there will be new
lessons learned from Harvey but as the
waters have receded and you can now
access emergency rooms like this one
hospitals are preparing for a new influx
of patients Margaret Chris thank you